alors guillaume genton qui est un petit
nouveau c'est un spécialiste média dit
doudou tout vient d'où tu viens guillaud
je viens d'ici sur les i tous les jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu connais tous eurent activé il est
beau gosse pas il est beau gosse dit
nous les filles parce que c'est vrai que
nous entendons mêlée miron sachez qu'on
est très très annie guillot mémoire est
vrai et c'est un petit ben vers san siro
fawcett est une belle personne au finish
boulot face à l'autre hostile jeudi dans
balances ton peuvent vous aviez un
invité fil rouge le controversé yassine
belattar bio j'ai adoré 660 mille
téléspectateurs bravo et merci
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors voilà en mâchant que l'idée très
bonne et je trouve que c'est très confus
en fait on sait pas qui présente
l'émission c'est willy rovelli qui ouvre
après c'est olivier minne qui reprend
après le père fouras il ya dix mille
personnages on comprend rien il ya des
épreuves via des fonds verts ils ont
rajouté une voix off c'est sûr produit
et c'est dommage que l'idée du parc
d'attractions c'était vachement bien
propre et cela c'est l'attention des cta
des lunettes ça va plus vite leur style
on lui je vais demander à mes deux
assistants stylisme de venir me
rejoindre pour aider à relooker j'ai
perdu mes deux assistants silice et bien
sûr matthieu delormeau qui fait son
retour aujourd'hui
merci merci qui va relancer des bâtisses
à bruce wayne
guillaume genton exhortons à qui on a on
n'inventera rien tu peux dire aux
téléspectateurs
je t'ai tout appris au niveau du site
bien sûr je suis ton conseiller style et
moi visagiste voilà exactement je suis
con con si des stylistes et sportif
exacte du sport avec moi guillaume
genton qu'est ce t'en penses quoi
on attend quelque chose de très casual
quatre jours le mainstream d'accord
c'est quoi tes conneries ça c'est la
mode ce que tu le connais pas ben voilà
c'est quoi alors est ce que tu peux
est-ce que tu payes cash est ce que tu
veux faire bouger tant le look de 2021
pour vous gilles ouaki image lui c'est
un look de 2004 nous dit le mec qu'a la
gueule de vincent lagaf
alors quelque chose de très coloré un
peu bling bling j'adore les couleurs
pour quelque chose d'une guerre non non
non c'est pas nouveau mathieu si ces
nouveaux bateaux non non non écoute moi
bien mais la passe pour doublons dans
l'émission sache le faire au match et il
va lui même il n'a pas un chiffre à nous
donner quelque chose si vous voulez quoi
comme chiffres marc vazy de nous un
chiffre de 9 9 quoi bon samaritain un
million 3 le daf faire un très bonne
audience hier merci à la bravo tu rien à
la télé je voudrais faire des lunettes
vous êtes quelqu'un aime bien cyrille
damien médiatique mais j'avoue que du
talent c'est pas parce qu'il n'est plus
beau qui fait j'aime
qu'est ce qui dit guy lux ça va
on parle comme d'une inconnue maintenant
je me hallyday elle aurait pu mettre mon
johnny l'a dit le client pense quoi je
pense que laëtitia côté le fasse et en
prend plein la gueule
voilà voilà elle a dit les fois johnny
hallyday ça va c'est pas non plus dire
si c'est ça ton avis guise un travail et
un nul en perte inra banon et l'orient
n'est pas du très mauvais début
d'émission et luxe et plus on est pro
des merveilles bonne et la mauvaise
semaine loup hier soir tf6 orthez à
petit niveau nouveautés cleaners les
experts du ménage c'est un marché guy
lux 528 me téléspectateurs 2,5 pour cent
de parts de marché ils ont fait un bon
score ménagères 5%
donc c'est plutôt pas mal c'est un bon
démarrage mais non ces moyens les moyens
d'accord guy guy guy turcotte là vous
l'attaquez vous lassez amis vous êtes
une belle personne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
guignol il faut que tu dises qu'on est
très très très près à brion et du sport
ensemble
voilà une belle histoire ensemble bien
sûr boire il joue vite devenu sport
cardio ben oui bien sûr il est avec moi
ah ça se voit les prix ce que toi aba'a
bon ça se voit oui les jeunes et minces
côtoyer maintenant vous allez que du
cardio ensemble ouais bien sûr là où je
connais une piscine and away ne
m'atteint régulièrement et les chaînes
mal est déjà fait sachez qu'on bat simon
ammann ouais à l'épatant nouveau
meilleur ami de l'année ça y est elles
ont mis sa fille tu me fais du roi zanka
marrant mais je vous ai lu que vous
allez répondre oui ça fait quatre mois
s'annoncent en étudie la question avoir
choisi guillaume un [ __ ] que mathieu à
ce passé l'élu il est plutôt s'effriter
là là où j'ai voulu m'inscrire moi il
n'y avait pas de place mallet un nombre
de membres maximum rectum en bas lui lie
des prix oui on voit ça après merci